before we talk about what happened in
the local elections I'm quite interested
to get your thoughts on Labour's new
policy announced today that they want to
guarantee no tax rises for people
earning under eighty five thousand
pounds a year leaving the door open of
course for higher taxes for those on
over that amount
do you think it's a good policy for them
to be having yes I do I think it's very
sensible we want to make it clear no
matter what might be said about us we're
actually on the side of ordinary
families wanting to get on having
aspiration having ambitions for their
future and that we want to be fair to
people across the board and I think the
the pledge on things like v80 is
particularly important because that's
always being the Conservatives weapon of
choice are you tying your hands though
by refusing to put up taxes for such a
large number of people what are a
certain extent yes but you know so many
people are really under pressure really
feeling much worse off and a lot of
people are suffering from cuts to things
like tax credits and so on so I think
it's the right thing to do to give
people reassurance because the
Conservatives are bound to say we will
put up everybody's taxes massively
because they always say that no matter
what it says in our manifesto oh no
matter what the likelihood now you've
represented Derby South since 1983 and
this year of course Derbyshire council
had turned from red to blue the first
time that's happened when Labour's in
opposition I mean for someone
representing the area and having such a
long history with the area that must
mean pretty heartbreaking to see yes I
was very sorry to see it and it's
unfortunate because I think they were a
good County Council and the last time we
had a conservative County Council I
think a lot of people who voted for them
regretted it very sharply afterwards but
you know these things happen it may be
the first time we've lost one in
opposition but it isn't the first time
we've lost the County Council we just
have to work hard to get it back so why
do you think it is that people in
Derbyshire in the constituency that you
represent why are they turning away from
labour well in my constituency there
wasn't an election this was a county
council election and you know people
people are disillusioned people are fed
up
and it's natural and to be fair the
government has done a very very good job
of blaming local authorities for all the
problems people are facing and and very
many people seem to a swallow the
government line oh and it's your council
that's doing this to you
when actually councils Tory labor
liberal whatever they are are being
driven by cuts from the government cuz
you say that people fed up so why are
they not taking out on conservatives why
they taking out on labor them that's
what I'm struggling to understand well I
mean we've got a mixed picture it hasn't
happened everywhere it's very clear I
know hundreds I mean I was talking to my
colleague Vernon Coker who tells me that
in his constituency they returned all of
the of the county counselors for labor I
mean a lot of nearly has 100 I'm not
don't get me wrong I am not pretending
it was a really bad result I am NOT
saying that all I'm saying is it wasn't
true everywhere and what we've got to do
is find out where things went right and
repeat it now and Jeremy Corbyn said in
the wake of those council results that
labor was closing the gap on the
conservative so John MacDonald talking
about Wales for example said it wasn't
the wipe out people expected there was
that almost celebratory conference in
Manchester after Andy Burnham one there
where Rebecca long Bailey describes
Jeremy Corbyn as the next prime minister
on a day when you lost all those seeds
do you think the leadership and those
around the leadership really get the
fight that Labour's in right now I think
they do but I think that you don't
encourage people to realise that it's
important how they vote and to vote for
you by being totally defeatist and I
think the thing that is the the other
morning I heard somebody on the radio
saying that they made my blood run cold
to be honest with the prime minister
hasn't just got a plan for brexit she's
got a plan for Britain yeah I believe
that and I don't like the sound of it I
mean one of the things I was thinking
about just recently I don't know if you
saw this stories about that the man who
who died who made a point of pointing
out how much less his widow and family
will get
if he lived beyond a date which was I
think about a week ago and indeed that
has happened widows now have widowed
mothers now have 18 months grace when
they will get some support of the state
for themselves and their children to get
over the loss of a partner that's that's
not the kind of country I want to live
in and that's the kind of country to
reason a is promoting so why is it that
that Labor's traditional voters people
who would be affected by the policies
that you described and leaving a party
in droves are going towards the
Conservatives I think one of them I
think there are two problems which I
mean everybody always says it's
classical doesn't mean it's completely
wrong one of the problems is that they
don't necessarily know what we are
saying although hopefully we will
redress that a bigger problem I think is
that it's not really being brought home
to them yet what the present government
are actually doing in my opinion that's
the key reason why - reason they went
for an election it's for party purposes
not for them because of the national
interest but I think the key thing is
she knows perfectly well that a lot of
these changes are in the law but they're
only just coming in by the autumn people
might have caught on at the moment they
haven't really and if it doesn't affect
them
it hasn't sort of been brought home to
them and I think it's that lack of focus
on what the government's doing to
families that is one of our biggest
problems so the electorate been foolish
we think now I think they're just not
being kept very well in for food America
and you know if people don't fully
realize what's happening and haven't
taken it in they don't start to get
indignant and they don't realize the
risks that they may be running if she
gets a landslide heaven help our health
service our school service our public
services as a whole now of course the
and the polls suggest that if not a
landslide she's going to win an emphatic
majority there was a report this week in
The Times that Labour MPs had got
together and said that if Jeremy Corbyn
is a Labour lost more than 150 seats
which of course you did in the local
council elections then someone should
call on Jeremy Corbyn to go and you were
identified in this article as someone
having so
authority and respect I'd make that plea
to Jeremy Corbyn did you ever have any
of these conversations no I wouldn't
know whether anybody had those
conversation but certainly nobody's had
them with me I can assure you and do you
think that it would help if Jeremy
Corbyn wasn't the leader ahead of the
general election I think that if there's
one thing that the public do not want to
hear from labor at the moment it's about
any internal differences that we have
this is a general election we are
fighting to try and protect the national
interest and the people we were elected
to represent if we take time off from
that to argue about our own internal
differences were mad you said you were a
[ __ ] for nominating him for the leap if
somebody else said it and you agreed
well you know I thought let it go so you
don't think you're immoral then no what
I'm saying is I think now it's really
important that we're addressing and
standing up for the national interest
and for the people in this country
that's what we should all be doing and
if Labour do lose the selection should
Jeremy Corbyn resign then well we'll
worry about that when it happens it
hasn't happened yet you know what all my
life people have talked as if the
outcome of elections was a foregone
conclusion Oh so-and-so can't happen
people will never do that people can do
especially in our electoral system
people can do what they like how they
cast their votes will make a difference
to the outcome and people should
remember that they might get what they
vote for and look at what it is they'd
get let's not and move on from Jeremy
Coleman cuz of course it is easy just to
kind of scapegoat either leader for all
of labor's issues and actually they run
far deeper don't they that does feel in
some ways that Labour is struggling to
find a voice when on brexit for example
when sorry excuse me and labour
supporters are so divided between leave
and remain there seems to have been
almost a dearth of ideas from the people
across the country I divide it I mean
one of the things that Prime Minister
said that I think was totally wrong she
said the people are coming together and
Westminster is not I don't come free I'm
sorry to say but I don't see the people
coming together over bread's it I think
those of us who fear
that breads it could be extremely
damaging to our economy and to our
country's future are very fearful remain
very fearful and people who thought
breads it was the right thing are full
of hope yeah I'd love to think they're
right and what do you think that Labour
is doing enough as an opposition to try
and shape brexit because it does feel
form an outsider sometimes that the
party's position is very nuanced and so
there is a risk of just falling down
beneath the cracks not really being
solidly full brexit not really Riesling
solidly for remains such as the Liberal
Democrats you see I think the easy thing
is to say as a result of a Democrat duo
let's just let's just undo it or let's
just reverse it that doesn't respect the
decision of the British people I don't
like
I work pretend I don't like the decision
of the British people at all I'm very
fearful for the future of my
constituents but I accept that that's
the decision they made and so we have to
make the best of it making the best of
things isn't always clear-cut and
glamorous but it's actually what
practical politicians are supposed to do
and I wish I thought it was what the
Prime Minister's doing now you were
commissioned to write a report into wine
labour lost the 2015 general election
I'm just going to have a look now at
some of your conclusions which was an
inability to deal with issues of
connection like immigration a leader who
wasn't judged as strong as the leader of
the Conservatives exceptionally
vitriolic impersonal attacks in the
press I mean it's remarkable because you
could be talking about the current
situation for the Labour Party that can
do well yes there's a lot a lot in
common with what was happening then we
weren't able to overcome it last time
we've got a try-hard deviant as a risk
though that Labour can identify the
problems as you did there but there's
not much in the way of solutions no I
think a lot of our policies are the
right policies they are geared to help
the people who well actually the
majority of people and particularly the
people who most need help I think
there's a lot to be said for what the
Labour Party is saying and Stan
but this is the issue isn't it because
you're right some of the polling does
suggests that Labor's policies are
popular but they still don't really like
the messenger they're still not
benefiting you it's the message isn't
getting through one of the things that I
think is really really awkward almost
unpleasant about the background to this
election is the kind of triumphalist you
know we we must soar over everything I
want a massive majority I want a massive
mandate it doesn't to my mind and I say
this with respect because I do respect
her as a human being but I think I've
had rather more experience of
international negotiations and Teresa
may I don't think it makes a blind bit
of difference
as long as she's the prime minister
that's what makes the difference doesn't
matter what how big a majority she gets
this is all nonsense this is all to
serve the interests of the Conservative
Party but I do worry that the bigger the
majority the more they will feel they
can ride roughshod there's an awful lot
of public spending cuts in the pipeline
that haven't hit people yet why have she
gone now because in a year's time things
might look very different people ought
to think about that when they decide
where to put their cross now you
mentioned in answer your kind of
experience
it's a politician and I am quite
interested in your personal journey in
your years in Parliament because you
actually started off much closer to
Jeremy Corbyn on some issues so it more
left on some issues you voted for Tony
Benn for example I do in that sort of
infamous deputy leadership election so
while Jeremy Corbyn appears to have
stayed with those principles what's
changed for you I think I think you'll
find I haven't changed all that much
either and if I may say so part of the
problem with people in your profession
is do you have little boxes and you put
people in them and I've always been in
the little box labels something of the
order of soft left centre left I am
particularly moved the landscapes moved
around me quite often I tell you one
area where I genuinely have to change
and that is over Europe I was very very
much opposed and you know people say oh
nobody told us this that
yes actually those of us who didn't want
to stay in the common market did point
out to all the implications of us doing
so but we did and then the common market
itself changed yes all right it's not
exactly the trading group that people
thought that the Scandinavian countries
have come in it is now very much Europe
and I have become a prescient
pro-european because I think it's in
Britain's interests as someone who lived
through the effect of civil war really
the labor was in in that time how is it
compared to now oh I'm happy to say that
people are much more collegiate and
friendly really as days genuinely I
don't mean there isn't bad feelings
sometimes I don't mean that people don't
get very angry of course they do but I
don't there was a level of rage and
bitterness when even before I became an
MP but when I was working around the
party that there isn't now people people
have people have grown up this is it's a
lot nice that there are a lot more women
that might have helped that might have
helped and how is that you're not
Twitter might have helped as well oh yes
absolutely have you noticed